what do Snoop Doggy Dogg and the
incoming Democrat congressman have in
common too much I'm sorry to say we will
analyze their vulgar Minds particularly
as it relates to that mother effer with
the hat then Hollywood loses at the
Golden Globes and the Oscars beg Kevin
Hart to re agreed to host I offer my
novel solution to the awards show
problem
RBG misses a day at court and the
Vatican celebrates the Cuban Revolution
we will analyze what other popes have
had to say about the scourge of
socialism
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt oh so much to get to today
and I wouldn't be able to say even one
single word if I didn't have these
bright shiny teeth of mine and the
reason I have those bright shiny teeth
is because of quip the new year means
new resolutions and we've got one you
are working on twice every day it's your
oral health and with a quip electric
toothbrush sticking to good habits is
simple the guiding features are like a
built-in sports system for better
brushing so you can start a healthy
routining and stick to it
those are two very different things so
you stir everyone wants to start it well
not a lot of people keep it going right
now do it Equipe is superb it's got
sensitive sonic vibrations for an
effective clean its gentle on your
sensitive gums I've sensitive gums too
it's got a built-in two-minute timer
that pulses every 30 seconds to remind
you when to switch sides this one's very
important because otherwise you do the
thing that men do or there aren't all
right done you're done in eight seconds
probably not a good brushing it's got a
multi-use cover it works as a stand it
mounts to mirrors it looks really sleek
and cool and the brush heads are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just $5 I love mine my teeth look so
much better with an electric toothbrush
they I know you think you can still use
a stick like you're living like a
caveman in the woods you can use an
electric toothbrush this is equip is one
of the first electric toothbrushes
accepted by the American Dental
Association backed by over 25 thousand
dental professionals I love it I
especially love it because it travels
really easily it's much smaller than
those bazookas that we used to use as
electric toothbrushes and that's why
over 1 million people are happy to equip
starts are just 25 bucks if you go to
get
quip calm slash Knowles kanno wles right
now you can get your first refill pack
for free that is your first refill pack
for free at GE t q UI p comm slash
Knolls KO WL e s it at we've talked
about a lot of political analysts
recently we've talked about all the
great journals of political thought all
of the Talking Heads all of the pundits
we haven't unfortunately checked in yet
with one of the great political
philosophic minds of our time snoop
diggity Doo dog who has some thoughts on
the government shutdown not getting paid
right now ain't no [ __ ] way in the
world y'all can vote for Donald Trump
when he come back up again if you do if
y'all do vote for him y'all so stupid
love I'm saying that to y'all early all
you federal government people that's not
being paid as being treated unfairly
right they're not being paid that's so
terrible and this Punk look don't care
so I'm saying that to say this when we
get back on y'all get y'all jobs back in
his time to vote don't vote for that
please don't look what do you do you
just don't give a [ __ ] y'all honest
blue-collar hard-working people here is
suffering so if you don't care about
y'all you really don't give a [ __ ] about
us so damn - everybody down with Donald
Trump I said it yes Snoop Dogg him mmm
really profound really really thoughtful
I would say Snoop Dogg's take on the
government shutdown because nobody
speaks for honest hard-working
blue-collar Americans quite like Snoop
Doggy Dogg an accused murderer drug
accused drive-by shooter he got off by
that on the way he got off on the
drive-by shooting charge on the murder
charge although the jury was hung on his
manslaughter charge nobody nobody really
speaks for those hard-working
blue-collar Americans look quite like a
guy who's wearing probably $50,000 worth
of gold chains around his neck who gets
paid to just swear and curse on on songs
I put songs and quotes that nobody
released that's the voice of America
that
sit that's it that's well that's so you
have that on one side and then you've
got Donald Trump I really like it
because obviously if somebody likes
Snoop Dogg running his mouth like that
he makes Donald Trump look polite but
you might say Michael you know you're
really being unfair here this is an
unfair comparison to compare the
President of the United States just some
stupid rapper some guy who runs his
mouth and you know was involved with
gangs and all that's that's not a fair
comparison okay okay that's fair enough
let's compare what Snoop Dogg said to
what the incoming Democrat congressman
Rasheeda Talib had to say oh it's
exactly the same okay
which was which I don't know is that
congresswoman snoop diggity Doo dog is
that who that was I don't know there is
now no difference so now between profane
rappers and members of Congress and
there actually is something of a
symmetry here because I don't want to
let Donald Trump off the hook entirely
Donald Trump is a product of the popular
culture and so what's going on it's not
just showing how tawdry and despicable
the Democrats are although that's part
of it what it's showing is the effect of
culture on politics so Donald Trump is a
product of this popular culture and he's
helped shape the popular culture he's
been on TV we've known him for decades
and decades and by the way he was a
hip-hop icon for decades as well
his name was referenced in hip-hop songs
all the time until he ran for president
as a Republican and so you've got him
affecting that culture a little bit he's
he's had a little bit of a loose mouth
you might say although he's been much
less profane since he's been elected
president which is very nice and now you
see that the culture following that and
reacting to that even though the culture
caused that and you see Democrat
congressman trying to follow suit and
what this really is is a symptom of
something that's grown for a long time
which is people trying to do Donald
Trump who are not Donald Trump this
doesn't work a lot of people a see
Donald Trump is this anomaly he's this
crazy cultural figure and it and what
when he talks loose and he uses humor
and he's a little flippant in his
language that really works for him
they all try to do it too but they can't
do it because they're not Donald Trump
you remember when little Marco tried to
do it
he called me mr. meltdown let me tell
you something last night in the debate
during one of the breaks two of the
breaks
he went backstage he was having a
meltdown first he had this little make
up thing applying like makeup around his
moustache because he had one of those
sweat moustaches then then he asked for
a full-length mirror I don't know why
because the podium goes up to here but
he wanted a full-length mirror maybe to
make sure his pants weren't wet I don't
know
then now I call him little Marco I
actually kind of like Marco Rubio but
but there he's little Marco when he's
trying to be Donald Trump and failing
that's when he becomes little Marco he's
not little Marco before he's actually a
pretty smart guy is a pretty good
senator but when he does that he becomes
little Marco he degrades himself when he
tries to do this Rickles stick that he
can't do only Donald Trump can do it why
can't Ahnold Trump do it because we've
known him for a very long time and
because he's a show biz guy so and show
business is a skill it's a real skill
being able to be on camera knowing how
to work with television knowing how to
get a reaction from a live audience
these are the skills that show business
teaches you Donald Trump's been in it
for a very long time and we know him we
know that when he says a swear word we
know that when he speaks flippantly or
he uses an insult we know what that
means and we know what that doesn't mean
we know that he's not some vicious
murderer killer guy we know he's not
some we just he is what he is he's
Donald Trump he's over the weekend I was
at a friend's house and for Christmas
they got me Trump the game this is a
board game that came at and it's like
monopoly but way shadier you know it's
kind of way more chaotic it's actually a
very fun game and this game though it
didn't come out in 2016 didn't come out
in 2005 when when The Apprentice was on
the air that game came out in 1989 so at
least as far back as 1989 there was a
there was a game of with Donald Trump's
face on it this guy has been in the
popular consciousness for so long so he
can get away with a lot more we haven't
known Marco Rubio that long who is Marco
Rubio he kind of came up what five
seven eight years ago maybe we started
to hear about him that's not long enough
Rashidah to leave what do we know that
Rashida to leave we know she's an
anti-semite we know that she has
suggested that that certain Jews have
dual citizenship or do a loyalty and not
fully to their country we know that she
supports the BDS movement boycott divest
and sanction Israel she wants Israel
wiped off the map and she literally
wiped Israel off the map in her
congressional office she went to a map
of the world she took a sticky note
wrote the word Palestine on it and
covered up Israel she put it right she
actually in a symbolic way wiped Israel
off of the map that's what we know about
her so when she says things like this
where she uses words like mother effer
or whatever it's received very
differently when Trump does it a guy
that we've known for forty years we
think oh that's kind of funny
all right nothing's gonna rock the boat
but that's okay oh that's just from
being Trump when this random anti-semite
that we've just met I mean she just got
into the popular consciousness comes out
and starts screaming mother-effer about
our president we take that very
differently that could be a dangerous
thing especially when she wants to wipe
a us-ally off of the map that's why it
doesn't work she's not the only one by
the way who who has been guilty of this
you know my my good friend my old
neighbor
I called her Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
she has been getting in the news
constantly and I've got to tell you
she's been saying very stupid things we
will talk about all of those we will
answer all of her very stupid and
dangerous points but I got to give her
credit she is really good at politics
she's really good at it she is I've said
it for a long time she's a shrewd
politician she is a freshman
congresswoman she has accomplished zero
in her life before getting elected to
Congress she's lied about her upbringing
she she wasn't doing any she was a
community organizer and she was working
as a bartender to pay the bills for a
little bit before she ran for Congress
voting records show that she was still
living with her parents until 2016 up in
Northern Westchester a woman of zero
accomplishment has dominated the
national and sometimes international
news
that requires immense skill it's what
makes her dangerous and it's what makes
her ignorance dangerous and it wouldn't
was what makes her ideology dangerous
here is Alexandria Cassio Cortez talking
about how she's gonna pay for her awful
socialist programs to Anderson Cooper
how are you going to pay for all of this
no one asks how we're gonna pay for this
space force
no one asked how we paid for a two
trillion dollar tax cut we only ask how
we pay for it on issues of housing
health care and education how do we pay
for it with the same exact mechanisms
that we pay for military increases for
the space force for all of these
ambitious policies there are Democrats
obviously who are worried about defect
in the party Democratic Senator Chris
Coons said about left-leaning Democrats
if the next two years is just a race to
offer increasingly unrealistic proposals
it'll be difficult for us to make a
credible case we should be allowed to
govern again what makes it unrealistic
how to pay for it
we pay more per capita in health care
and education for lower outcomes than
many other nations and so for me
what's unrealistic is is what we're
living in right now yes and no some of
what she said is true
very little but some of it is true she
talks about per capita health care
spending with regard to advanced
socialist economies like the United
Kingdom one thing we have to remember is
that the entire rest of the world
depends on American health care
innovation they are all three riders on
our health care innovation when that
engine of innovation goes away when all
those drugs that we develop go away
their health care regimes see their
costs skyrocket necessity quality of
care decrease all of those other regimes
also have much lower quality of care
they have much longer wait times people
die waiting in line for surgery that
doesn't happen here in the United States
or it doesn't need to happen here in the
United States and most jarring ly for
human dignity you have the cases like
little Alfie Evans like other little
babies that we've seen just in the
United Kingdom who were sick who had
conditions where their parents wanted to
take them out of the government hospital
take them to the United States take them
to Italy take them elsewhere for
treatment and the government said no
there was one case where the parents
wanted to take the baby
of the hospital and bring the baby the
Pope said the baby could come to to a
hospital next to the Vatican and they
would arrange for Italian citizenship
and they would make it all happen and
the government said no your baby is
gonna stay here and die you have no
right to try to save your baby's life
that's socialism that's socialist
medicine to say nothing of the tax rates
in some of these places so Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez points to some countries
that have socialist health care regimes
she says look it works fine there there
are some reasons why in in some ways it
does work there but one reason is
extraordinarily high tax rates and now
Alexandria is talking about raising the
tax rates to 70% effectively 82.7%
on people in places like New York or
California she's throwing a lot of this
out there she is going full socialist
full hog against the wall we could spend
I suppose we should spend at full shows
talking about why socialist health care
doesn't work why it's so bad for human
dignity why the economics don't work
white especially wouldn't work at the
United States were to enact it but
suffice it to say for now I just want to
point out this one trick that she is
using that socialists to use all the
time
Anderson Cooper says how are you gonna
pay for this health care program which
will cost 40 trillion dollars over ten
years and she says well the same way
we're gonna pay for spaceforce
now your space forces this program
Donald Trump talked about a new branch
of the military to deal with outer space
when people hear that they say okay
there's one government program space for
us and there's another government
program socialist health care and if you
can pay for one you can pay for the
other right wrong the cost of space
force is estimated to be thirteen
billion dollars over five years it's
hard to predict out what health where or
what what costs will be particularly in
a in a military program like that but
let's just double it let's just say that
it's 26 billion over ten years
you've got 26 billion over 10 years for
space force and you've got 40 trillion
dollars over ten years for health care
you were talking about a difference of
not just an order of magnitude but
almost twice an order of magnitude and
yet when people here are these numbers
it's all the same if it ends in iliyan
it's all the same if the
numbers bigger than a thousand it's all
the same when when you hear million
billion trillion quadrillion
quintillions is a zillion you know
intellectually that there is a
difference but in your mind when you're
visualizing it you don't visualize the
difference and I don't know if Ocasio is
extraordinarily ignorant she might be or
if she's being obtuse here and being
crafty and clever to try to cram through
this awful healthcare system of hers but
that's the trick she's playing on she
thinks that you don't know the
difference between a billion and a
trillion the difference between a
billion and a trillion is a full order
of magnitude it's a bunch of zeros and
so even just consider our annual budget
for serious she says where are we gonna
get the money for space for us our
military actions in Syria cost about
fifteen billion dollars per year space
force will cost thirteen billion dollars
over five years so one year to pulling
the troops out of Syria which President
troop has said he's going to do one year
will more than pay for five years of
space force what would we have to do to
pay for okay she owes health care regime
we would have to double tax receipts to
the federal government which by the way
isn't even as simple as doubling the
income tax rate what is the income tax
right now effectively you could be
paying 40% over 40% in effective taxes
when you factor in state and local and
all the other stuff but it's not even
that simple because when you raise taxes
that high UD you disincentivize people
working in the economy you
disincentivize production so just to use
an example that she keeps bringing up if
you raise the tax rate to 70 percent
federal on someone even making ten
million dollars and then you've got to
take into effect state and local let's
say it raises that to eighty two point
seven percent if you live in New York
why would you ever make more than ten
million dollars what you would have no
incentive to do it when you know that
the vast majority of all that money will
be confiscated so you have two choices
you can either hide the money figure out
some crafty way to get the money out of
the country or hide it in some sleight
of hand on the accounting books or you
just don't do it why would I ever work
83% of the year for the federal
government ain't gonna happen baby
no chance so that that distance and I
mean this is this is also what destroys
socialist economies is that you you just
have no incentive to be productive
whatsoever we are a wonderful engine of
growth because Americans are productive
but if you start confiscating all our
wealth guess what we're not going to be
productive at all now when you point out
these things when you point out
mathematical reality to say nothing of
moral realities mathematical realities
political realities of socialism this is
Oh Cassie as best response that you can
muster the criticisms of you is that
your math is fuzzy the Washington Post
recently awarded you four Pinocchios
for misstating some statistics about
Pentagon spending if people want to
really blow up one figure here or one
word there I would argue that they're
missing the forest for the trees I think
that there's a lot of people more
concerned about being precisely
factually and semantically correct than
about being morally right but being
factually correct is important
absolutely important and whenever I make
a mistake I say okay this was clumsy and
then I restate what my point was but
it's it's not the same thing as the
president lying about immigrants it's
not the same thing at all just listen to
what she said she said some people are
focused on being factually and
semantically correct rather than being
morally right now this is the second
trick that socialists always use that
Ocasio is using here which is false
dichotomies to create a false a couple
of choices to be morally right requires
that you be correct she seems not to
understand that the word semantics means
meaning itself it means the meaning of
words so to be factually not correct is
to be right if they're synonymous to be
right with regard to the meaning of real
things to be morally correct is to be
right it's to be right with regard to
the the meaning of real things the part
of what she's doing here
and I think this comes actually out of
her ideology and out of her culture is
she speaking as though truth doesn't
matter I mean there she is literally
saying truth doesn't matter she says it
doesn't matter if you are factually
correct as long as you're morally right
of course that sentence doesn't mean
anything that's like gobbledygook it's
like say bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
it's like saying you don't need to be
correct as long as you're correct
blahblahblah it's all that were well II
and double-talk that she has but I think
in her ideology which is totally
relativistic this is true you can just
say things regardless of what they mean
regardless because as long as it has the
intended political effect you have
achieved your goal she doesn't care
about saying true things she doesn't
care how she's gonna pay for 40 trillion
dollars all she cares about is the
political effect of her in government
taking over health care she wants to
take more power for the government power
away from people because she is totally
confident she has the faith and the zeal
of a convert for her religion which is
socialism that once the government all
has all that power everything will be
fine as long as we don't have all that
freedom out there for people to make
their own choices as long as we take
that back we'll work out everything in
the end that'll just be accounting this
is completely morally obtuse this is
completely wrong there is right and
there is wrong there is truth and there
is falsehood those are real things
they're not relative they're not
subjective constructs you know been
often that says that phrase facts don't
care about your feelings this is the
inverse event this is exactly the
opposite
she's saying my feelings don't care
about your facts I don't care if you are
factually correct and of course
Anderson Cooper but was the one who just
sort of let her get away with it he
pushed back very slightly but he let her
get away with it this is what is so
wicked about it and we'll get to in a
minute
how the Vatican was celebrating the 60th
anniversary of the Cuban Communist
revolution how perverse that is many
Popes have realized how perverse that is
socialism is a perversity is it is anti
human and this is what it's all about
it's not just about raising your taxes
it's not just even about taking away
your healthcare choices or your
employment choices
or your labor choices or whatever what
it's what this is about
is lies versus reality it's about that
quote that Democrats always say on the
campaign trail they quote Shaw when he
says some people see the world as it is
and ask why I dream things that never
were and ask why not they forget that
those words that Shaw wrote were in the
mouth of the serpent tempting Eve in the
garden from a play called back to
Methuselah that's what it boils down to
Ocasio is completely right to talk about
moral correctness to say this is not
just an issue of physical realities this
is an issue of moral and metaphysical
realities it's true
socialism is all about morality it's all
about ethics these systems of economies
that we're talking about ultimately this
is a moral question this is a religious
question this is an ethical question and
socialism is anti-human it is wrong it
is rotten down to its core it is a
scourge and a pest and a plague on
humanity and we should talk about it in
those terms we will in just a minute but
we do have to cover more of the
government shutdown because this is this
is the big political question that
nobody's talking about coz nobody's
feeling it dick durbin major Senate
Democrat points this out he sees no end
in sight for the shutdown from what
you're describing it doesn't sound like
there is any progress how close are we
to ending this shutdown well I can't say
that we're close because the president's
made it clear he doesn't care he's
prepared to see a shutdown for months
and he even said years and reaffirmed
that before the cameras it was stunning
to hear a president the United States
say that about his own government the
government we elected him to lead but
that is his position it's nobody cares
nobody cares is the issue that's the big
problem this government shutdown thus
far has been a major win for Trump don't
just take my word for it look at the
public polling there was a poll out from
Rasmussen which is a right-leaning
polling firm but they they get things
right a lot of the time it showed that
only six percent of Americans say that
this shutdown has had a major impact on
their lives
now of course nobody watching this show
or listening to this show I bet zero
percent of people watching or listening
say that the shutdown has had a major
impact
on your lives even if you work for the
federal government even if you're a
federal employee who's not being paid
right now you know you're gonna get back
pay there's a little bit of a pinch in
the short term and everybody's really
sorry for that nobody wants people who
are working not to be paid but every
everyone knows after every government
shutdown the workers get paid they get
paid for all the time that they weren't
being paid and actually even employees
who called in sick which is happening to
a slightly higher degree right now even
they get paid so ultimately workers end
up actually usually getting more money
because of the shutdown than they would
otherwise but so you see six percent who
say that this shutdown has had a major
impact on their lives twenty one percent
say they didn't even know that there's a
shutdown going on right now
so more than three times that number of
people aren't even aware that there is a
shutdown because we don't feel it at all
even the national parks aren't really
closing very little is happening right
now you can still go to the airport you
can still travel everything is going
basically just fine now this isn't gonna
last forever Donald Trump has said that
he'll let this thing go on for months or
even years and because he's pursued this
madman strategy in office because he's
doing things that seem erratic he's
always keeping his opponents on their
toes maybe he means it maybe he's really
willing to do that as you approach tax
season you're gonna see two arguments
here if the government by some very slim
chance we're still going if the shutdown
we're still going on at that point
because you've got a lot of Americans
who prepay their taxes and they'll get a
refund at tax time they'll be upset if
they don't get it as for me I don't do
that I pay my taxes when tax time is due
I refuse to give the government an
advance on them that's money or much of
an advance on the money that I owe them
when tax time comes around so actually
I'm all for it keep the IRS shut down
I'm gonna owe that money I don't want to
pay them their money works for me but
what's gonna happen you've still got a
lot of agencies funded for the next
month even for the next two months so
Trump has a lot of leeway here you're
already starting to see cracks among
Democrats Nancy Pelosi says the wall is
immoral other Democrat reps are breaking
with her and saying well it's not
immoral
we all have walls around our houses
the Vatican has a wall around around it
you wouldn't say that's immoral we've
got every other country as a wall you
wouldn't say that's immoral
Democrats ten years ago we're voting for
parts of the wall anyway so I think
you're starting to see a crack there
you're not really seeing a crack from
the White House I think as it stands
right now there's a good chance we win
this battle it won't be the end of the
line because with five billion dollars
you're not going to be able to build the
whole wall you're only gonna be able to
build a part of it but it looks like
it's moving in our direction all of the
polling shows that's still going well I
hope President Trump doesn't miss this
opportunity here at a certain point this
poll numbers are gonna reverse but right
now things looking very good now I know
I know that you were all you're all
waiting with bated breath to hear what I
think about the Golden Globes you
watched it didn't you did you you didn't
oh me neither it's okay i watch clips of
it and I've got a novel solution for the
awards show problem we'll also talk
about the 60th anniversary of the Cuban
Revolution and Ruth Bader Ginsburg who
for the first time is missing Court oral
arguments because of a medical problem I
wonder what that means for 2019 we will
get to it but first go to Daly wire.com
you have to do it you have to subscribe
give us your money keep me in employment
you know at all times
Ben is waiting outside the door waiting
to hand me my pink slip if we don't make
money from the from the subscribers and
viewers don't give him the satisfaction
go to daily wire.com it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the Unruh claimant show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get another Kingdom
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
coming up on Thursday you get to ask
questions in backstage which is
happening a lot now you get you get so
much you get so much but this is what
matters this is what mother-effing
matters you know I'm not good at talking
like a leftist I can't it sounds weird
when I do it but get it but I want the
enthusiasm of it and and you'll be
really enthusiastic about your left is
tears tumblr because if we build this
wall oh you're gonna need if you if we
build this wall we're also gonna get a
moat and you're gonna need the leftist
here's tumblr to fill it up and float on
top of it go to daily wire comm we will
be right back with a lot more
the Golden Globes were last night don't
care me neither but I actually do care
for what it means about the culture
obviously no one's watched most of these
movies no one cares what these
celebrities think about anything but
there was an amazing opening monologue
and it showed you just how far our
popular culture has fallen it was truly
astounding here is just a little bit of
it and the reason is we're the only two
people left in Hollywood who haven't
gotten in trouble for saying something
offensive Oh Sandra that reminds me you
know what race of people really gets
under my skin and the Hollywood half
marathon because it messes up all the
traffic you know oh yeah I hate that
race of people it's the worst race of
people now we know what you guys are
thinking Andy Samberg and Sandra Oh the
two nicest people in showbiz this
thing's gonna be a snooze but not so
fast because you fools are all about to
get roasted your bass style hope you're
wearing your flip-flops Hollywood cuz
we're about to scorch some earth damn
right rip it is alright who we got here
we got well if it isn't Spike Lee yeah
mister do the right
yeah well I'll tell you does the right
thing you as a director lifetime fan
can't wait to see what you do next BAM
face that's how so it goes on like this
for 10 or 11 minutes they go on the
whole joke being here that they can't
say anything mean or offensive because
they'll lose their entire careers and
Andy Samberg is actually pretty funny
he's is a little hit or miss but he does
have a real comic skill Sandra Oh does
not she isn't funny she wasn't even
funny at this stick but what's
interesting about this stick is it's
obviously they're kind of joking about
how intense the Hollywood PC culture has
gotten that they can only say nice
things but then they just only say nice
things so it would if they had joked
about that and then there were some
break there were some turn there were
some challenge to that PC culture which
is so unfunny then I think it would have
really worked but they didn't do that
they just kept saying nice things which
was the most cowardly thing they could
have possibly done they actually had to
hide their cowardliness in a joke about
how cowardly they were but then they
never broke out of it so it just
remained cowardly that is the whole
point they had to have to presenting if
they only had one presenter that's too
big a target they had to have a man and
a woman if they had two men that well he
couldn't do that they had to have them
be of different races if it were two
white people that you couldn't possibly
do that and but then they just indulged
the whole thing and then the most
pathetic part of all of it was they
actually turned it they made an earnest
turn at the very end and Sandra Oh gave
an impassioned earnest political speech
about what I have no idea I said yes to
the fear of being on this stage tonight
because because I wanted to be here to
look out into this audience and witness
this moment of change and I'm not
pulling myself
I'm not fooling myself next year could
be different it probably will be but
right now this moment is real trust me
it is real because I see you and I see
you all of these phases of change and
now so will everyone else oh it's so
awkward because they don't I mean this
whole shtick that Sandra was doing is so
poorly performed I mean it's so
ridiculous and over-the-top and
obviously disingenuous that even the
audience there all of whom have been
indoctrinated in the PC culture they all
know how to perform they all know that
they're supposed to abide by certain PC
orthodoxies they start laughing you hear
the issues and I know it's real she's
mustering all that fake all those fake
tears you never see the tears run down
her face obviously because she's not a
very good actress she was I an ice and I
know it's real because I see you what
it's yeah we're here we've been here
yeah we were here last year too and so
the a couple people and more than a
couple people in the audience start
laughing but then they cut it off really
quickly because no she is performing
she's do people do this on stage
sometimes they and women do it obviously
more than men do they muster up this
like fake crying emotional thing and it
just is really pathetic I mean this was
really really sad what is she referring
to she said change is here
there's issue referring to the sexual
assault stuff how every every one of
these Hollywood degenerates is raping
everybody else is that which is but
there's change now because we're wearing
buttons on our lapels and there's change
cuz we have we have bracelets on our
wrists about times up and so it's
changed now is that what you're
referring to racial questions that
certain races weren't being cast a lot
in Hollywood and now they're being cast
a little more as a race or is it or is
it about the host so there are women
multiple hosts or why do what watching
this all I could think of was one of the
greatest PSAs that has ever been
aired the satirical PSA it was put up by
click hole to take the pledge I always
wanted to be part of something bigger
than myself to make a difference you go
through life and you see all this
injustice but you never really do
anything about it you don't know how I
have two little kids so I'm always
thinking about their future every
solution begins with just one person
stepping up and taking responsibility
that's why I'm taking the pledge I'm
dating the pledge because I care about
my community for my kids my grant for
you for me for us for us for them and
for me too a cool because I care about
the future and not just my future but
the future of everyone every single
person my baby boys taking the pledge is
about standing up for what matters and
what's right it doesn't matter if you're
black white Muslim Christian and Jewish
anyone can take the pledge you got my
brother to take the pledge and he got
his friend to do it I got everyone in my
school to take the pledge you get her to
take the pledge and she gets someone
else to get someone else and on and on
and on and suddenly we've got something
much bigger than any one of us take the
pledge Golden Globes go out there and
take the pledge this isn't just bad for
comedy when when they try to do this
earnestly this is also I mean this leads
to terrible leftist politics it points
out something that I try to I notice
this about that particularly hipster
Millennials but this is true of the left
broadly there is a culture now that's
taken over comedy for the last thirty
years probably which is irony now all of
comedy is centered around to irony
before it wasn't centered around irony
and and specifically ironic apathy that
we're all just everything's just to be
debunked and deconstructed and
everything's really lame and they're
really super cool and I don't care and I
don't mind I don't need to be excited
and I'm it doesn't matter I'm just
apathetic and everything's totally
ironic that culture of comedy has been
around since elite let's at least
Letterman and he sort of heralded that
change and sometimes it's funny
sometimes it's not but the thing with
irony if you live your life entirely
ironically hipsters getting stupid
tattoos because they look stupid
ironically getting certain tattoos the
thing with irony is that if you live
your
entirely ironically then there's no such
thing as irony then you're doing it
earnestly if you tell these jokes the
jokes about how we have to only say nice
things about everyone at the Golden
Globes and then that's all you do it's
no longer ironic you're doing it
earnestly and and this is true even of
these you know every award show has
awful political speeches nowadays over
the last 15 years and a Christian Bale
gave a truly ridiculous one last night
geezer over there
Adam he said he said he said I've got to
find somebody you can who can be
absolutely charisma free and reviled by
everybody so he went ask well be Bale in
it you know thank you and for all the
competition I will be cornering the
market on charisma for you what do you
think Mitch McConnell next that could be
good
[Applause]
thank you to Satan to giving me
inspiration on how to play this role
some people are confused hearing that
because we never hear Christian Bale
with his actual accent a Christian Bale
is English he was raised in Wales to
English parents and so that's his real
accent and he's talking about playing
Dick Cheney in the movie vice and he's
calling him a charisma free
blankety-blank and he thanks Satan for
giving him inspiration to play the role
something I just want to point out here
in awards shows when you won an Oscar or
Golden Globe
you used to thank God you used to get up
there I want to thank my friends and my
family my directors I want to thank God
for for being there and sustaining me
and inspiring me now you think Satan now
these people are thanking Satan and you
might say well he was telling a joke
well it's ironic well it's I read to
this and I write if you live ironically
100% of the time then the irony isn't
irony anymore it's earnest and and this
guy is actually getting up there in
thanking Satan you know something has
gone seriously wrong with these awards
shows when you get up there and thank
Satan by the way just a little point on
Christian Bale Christian Bale was
arrested in 2008 for domestic violence
against his mother and sister Benny's
going after Dick Cheney as this charisma
free blankety-blank who's inspired by
Satan maybe one should look in the
mirror
maybe mr. Bale should pluck the plank
out of his own eye before looking at the
speck in his neighbor's eye but
unsurprisingly in early ratings right
now the this Golden Globe show was down
to a four year low maybe a decade low it
was down over last year the ratings are
plummeting for these award shows and
they're plummeting especially for the
Oscars you remember that blow up they've
chose Kevin Hart the comedian to host
the Oscars then they found that he made
a gay joke ten years ago so there was
this big fake faux outrage uproar a huge
non traversée and the Academy prep
basically sold him out and Kevin Hart
decided he wasn't going to host the
Oscars anymore now they're in a bind
because there's no one to host the
Oscars if the new standard is that you
if you've ever told a gay joke you can't
host the Oscars then no comedian ever
can host the Oscars and beyond that no
human being walking on this earth can
host the Oscars everybody
is told a gay joke everybody's heard a
gay joke everybody's laughed at a gay
joke and if you say that you haven't
you're lying Ellen DeGeneres I am
certain has told many gay jokes in her
life and she had Kevin Hart on to
basically ask him on behalf of the
Academy to come back and host the Oscars
he or she is begging I I called the
Academy today cuz I really want you to
host the Oscars I think that I was so
excited when I heard that they asked you
I thought it was an amazing thing I knew
how important it was and how it was
dream so I called them I said Kevin's on
I have no idea if he wants to come back
and host but what are your thoughts and
they were like oh my god we want him to
host we feel like that maybe he
misunderstood it was handled wrong or
maybe we said the wrong thing but we
want him to host what whatever we can do
we would be thrilled and he should hurt
I mean I mean the Academy is is saying
what can we do to make this happen yeah
I bet they are because now they're up a
certain creek without a paddle and
they've got no one that they can
possibly use I have a novel bit of
advice for this award show problem and
this is my advice to the Academy if
you're watching let Oscar die put him
out of his misery stop airing it this
this has been building for a very long
time the awards show is insufferable
that's why nobody is watching it the
Oscars ratings were at a 44 year low
last year and that was a 20% drop over
the previous year it is dying it is dead
the reason it is dead is not because it
had to die but because there's awful
people in the Academy haven't made it
die they've made it all about politics
they've made it all about leftist
politics and also because the movie
business is dead the movies that win
awards at the Oscars nobody has ever
seen the movies that people go and see
the three movies a year all of which are
superhero movies or not winning Oscars
and they don't deserve to win Oscars
because they're not very good movies so
it's it's dead it's over kill it move on
we'll stop trying to resuscitate this
zombie of Oscar he was glorious in his
day the American film industry was
glorious in its day and now it's dead
and you killed it you should look in the
mirror and feel deep shame about that
and then move on because it's over the
Cuban Revolution I have to get to this
it's the 60th anniversary of the Cuban
Revolution and the Vatican of all places
the Vatican News Service honored that
Cuban Revolution it sent out a post it
said quote the Cuban Revolution
celebrated its 60th anniversary this
January 1st 2019 on the island the
historic anniversary was celebrated with
the ceremony in Santiago de Cuba in the
cemetery of santa ifigênia where Fidel
Castro is buried who died November 25th
2016 to the main national forces the
dictator Fulgencio Batista fled on 26
months of guerrilla war led by brothers
Fidel and Raul Castro Fidel Castro
proclaimed the beginning of the
revolution the victory of the
counterculture it is celebrating this is
it the Vatican News Service speaking for
the Vatican is celebrating the Cuban
Revolution this is awful this is
horrific
thankfully they took down that post the
the church needs to stop this the church
needs to stop playing footsie with
socialists the Pope has done it the
Vatican has done it in recent years this
is a major break with church history
this is a major break with the spirit of
Christianity it's wrong it's anti human
and they need to stop doing it broadly
Protestant churches as well need to stop
doing this there is a sense now pushed
by hippie-dippie left wingers that Jesus
was just a really nice hippy socialist
and we've all perverted his message
because he was such a socialist this is
not true just a few statistics on the
Cuban Revolution 60 years later in the
last 10 years there have been at least
18,000 political prisoners in Cuba it's
hard to get accurate numbers obviously
because it's a totalitarian regime but
that's a good estimate 2 million Cubans
live outside of Cuba because of the hell
that the Castro is inflicted I went down
to Cuba visited there when it was
briefly semi-open I talked to a lot of
Cubans let me tell you something they
don't wear Che Guevara t-shirts in Cuba
they wear American flag sewn onto their
clothing and on their bicycles when they
can afford them that is the protest
because they want freedom and they hate
communism because communism is slavery
and it is truly destroyed that people we
know that the Castro regime death toll
is estimated between 35 and 141 thousand
people we know 5,000 people were
executed immediately after the Castro
takeover to say nothing of the fact that
the communist regime in Cuba almost blew
up the entire world during the Cuban
Missile Crisis
there's nothing moral about socialism
there's nothing good about socialism
it's awful it's wicked and it's anti
human by the way as the Vatican applauds
and celebrates the Cuban Revolution
don't forget that the Cuban Revolution
specifically attacked Christianity it
was an atheistic revolution a lot of
Catholics including a bishop were
permanently exiled from the from the
country this after the Vatican and Pope
Francis has asked earlier in the year to
Underground Chinese bishops to step down
in favor of government Communist Party
apparatchik bishops we know that the
Pope has regularly attacked capitalism
and free markets we need a a to counter
this we finally must counter
as it affects in this case specifically
the Catholic Church but Protestant
churches as well
socialism is wicked and terrible and it
must be opposed vigorously john paul ii
knew this very well in his encyclical
chant as he most honors he wrote float
it would appear that on the level of
individual nations and of international
relations the free market is the most
efficient instrument for utilizing
resources and effectively responding to
needs a pope before him leo xiii also
wrote even more clearly about socialism
he referred to socialists as a wicked
confederacy he referred to them as a
pest an evil growth he said socialists
steal the very gospel itself with a view
to deceive more easily the unwary he
called it a plague that's exactly what
it is that's what we should call it when
we talk about the 60th anniversary of
the Cuban Revolution that's how we
should talk about it when we respond to
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez another young
attractive very likable woman who's
trying to push this plague in this pest
and this wicked evil growth on humanity
again this old decrepit awful idea that
will not die we need to fight it we need
to fight it in the strongest terms and
we should give no quarter to people who
are trying constantly to resuscitate
that awful zombie plague all right
that's our show we've run out of time
we'll get to more tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolan show I'll see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018